hello oh hey Brittany  are you talking so weird happy wired  it's an epidemic guys come check this  out it's happening to everyone just look  around you this is pretty scary you guys  it's not this is BS not everyone is  getting married you guys I got  it's my brother he's engaged he was so  young he hadn't even been to a strip  club yet I don't wanna buy a wedding  gift for an engagement gift is too  expensive losing my friends pathetic I'm  going crazy you solo you think Zach's  been acting kind of strange hold on baby  I gotta tie my shoe are we gonna have to  do them all career at the reception I  don't know I don't know how to do a  Marvin why is this happening  how long before it's you here comes the  bride all dressed and why  will you marry me will you  you